if there's one guy who can replace Matt
Damon in the porn movies it's the dude
who was taking on those big flying
bastards with a bow and arrow and the
Avengers The Bourne Legacy the Bourne
Legacy is another Bourne movie without
Jason Bourne Jeremy Renner plays Aaron
cross who was another soldier who was in
the same program that Jason Bourne was
in you know the whole yeah we're super
soldiers and we're badasses program yeah
that's the program and had the dirty
secrets of the company are coming out so
there's like hey let's just cut the
program and distance ourselves from all
this cut the program means wipe out
everyone who's involved for people who
don't speak spy movie and so they do
that but Hawkeye is a survivor and so
now super soldier Jeremy Renner comes
back he gets Rachel Weisz and so we're
like hey we have a fourth Bourne movie I
guess this movie is called the Bourne
Legacy so you expect to see the things
that you loved from the Bourne movies in
it but you really don't get any of that
they shoehorn these Jason Bourne moments
in this movie when they can you know the
news is like oh this just in Jason
Barnes in Manhattan just so the audience
knows this is still a Bourne movie but
at its core it lacked the things that I
liked about the Bourne movies I don't
need this to be a mindless action movie
among all the action in the Bourne
movies there was still a character we
cared about fighting for a cause that we
liked and they had some really cool
close quarters combat CQC action necks
or break-in it was great this had a
couple of those moments but in the end
you like this feels like a great be
Jason Bourne movie this is what the
movie felt like as a whole for most of
this movie Jeremy Renner and Rachel
wives are going and doing their thing
they're following them they're trying to
catch up to them they're trying to find
out where they went they're using
cameras and satellites and I was like
holy [ __ ] this feels like a great beat
enemy of this day and a couple of fight
scenes later two hours into the movie
the action kicks on you're like - a
little too late it now feels like a
great be version of a Bourne movie I
mean Jeremy Renner was great in this
movie Rachel Wise was great in this
movie if there is a person I would put
in a Bourne movie without Jason Bourne
it would be Jeremy Renner the dudes a
badass he's a good actor and he could
completely kick the [ __ ] out of anyone
I'd like to see them fight Jason Bourne
and Aaron cross just going at it that
would be really cool but as a whole this
movie feels like a force equal to a
trilogy that it's springboarding off of
that it's not as good as other than the
movie just cuts off it's like Oh chasing
intense done well I guess that's the end
I mean I imagine it had to end but it is
hmm I feel like
it wasn't a Bourne movie and it was just
a spy movie I would almost be kind of
lenient on it I wouldn't be comparing it
to the Bourne movies and I'd be like
okay you know it's just a generic spy
movie paradox is I'd be like oh well
you've seen movies like this before it
feels like a great beat enemy of the
state and a great be Jason Bourne movie
it had a few really cool moments but
it's a two-and-a-half hour long movie
that's really not that interesting
ultimately Aaron crosses mission he's
like I need to go to Thailand and get a
pill that's what they're doing that's
the entire movie I imagine the sequel
could be cool if it has Jason Bourne in
it but at that point I feel like he
would overshadow Jeremy Renner so I
don't even know if they're gonna do that
we'll see though time will tell I will
say the Bourne Legacy given that it has
a few cool scenes is alright but you're
not gonna remember it in t-minus a
couple days yep already forgot it's a
bummer I wanted to love the movie but I
just didn't right so the Bourne movies
including this one we have all for now
what's your favorite comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more